How did you know how much sugar to
use in the smaller batch of cookies?
You probably noticed that 24 cookies
is half the number of cookies that
the recipe normally yields, 48.
And that means you probably knew that
you would need half as much sugar to
make half as many cookies.
That means you needed to find
half of one-half of a cup.
So that means you needed half as
much sugar as the original recipe,
so one-half cup, and
then you just took half.
And that gave us one-quarter cup.
One-fourth is one-half times one-half.
For both the numerator and
the denominator, please check one.
Do you add the numerators,
subtract the numerators,
multiply the numerators,
or don't change?
And for the denominators, do you add,
subtract, multiply, or don't change?